هو حلمك يا صغيري? حلمي هو ان
اطعم اخوتي. فتى سوري يبكي بعد
ليخرج من هذه الدوامة وفي طريقه
الى الخروج. ها هم نواب البرلمان
انصار ترامب. فهل فعلها الرجل
الاصفر ليثبت رجولته؟ مجلس الامن
الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي ونقل
زوجها للمستشفى والشكوك تطال
المغرب وجبهة بوليساريو المدعومة
من الجزائر للتوصل الى حل دائم
من ازماته؟ الاحداث والتطورات.
وبعد ان هددته الباسوس بالضرب.
طائرة مفخخة جديدة تعرف
بالمجنونة. فهل سيتم تجربتها في
ومقبول للطرفين ومدد مهمة الامم
المتحدة في المنطقة لعام اخر. ما
الثقة من مجلس النواب باغلبية
مطلقة ليتعهد السوداني بالقضاء
المتبادل. فهل تكون هذه الحكومة
بصيصة امل للشعب العراقي ليخرج
عجزه عن تأمين الطعام لاسرته. اي
حال هذا الذي تعيشه يا صغيري يا
الحرب الاوكرانية? يواصل بوتين
رسائله للغرب وتواصل واشنطن
زيارة مرتقبة لرئيس الصين شي جين
بينغ الى المملكة وعقد ثلاث قمم
الدولي دعا الى نافي المفاوضات
حول نزاع الصحراء الغربية بين
له من حلم سيضع الكثيرين في موقف
محرج. تركيا تكشف الستار عن
الجنوبية والتي قالت انها لم
تزود اوكرانيا باي اسلحة فتاكة
الامريكي لدراسات انتشار الاسلحة
والتجارب النووية ان ستة وسبعين
الصين اكبر خطر وذلك باعلان
المتحدث باسم المستشار الالماني
العراقي يتعاركون بالايدي خلال
جلسة منح الثقة لحكومة السوداني
لا يهدد. مجنون كوريا الشمالية
لا يمزح لا يلعب ولا يتم تهديده.
بكين ستتناول تعزيز الاقتصاد
الالماني. العقدة العراقية. بلد
واخيرا وبعد طول انتظار حكومة
السوداني تبصر النور. بعد نيلها
التدريبات لكبح جماح كيم ليأتي
الرد من مركز جيمس مارتن
العسكري مع الصين. حسنا نرغب في
اجراء اتصال مع الجانب الامريكي
على البطالة والفساد والعمل على
بناء اقتصاد قوي وتقوية اسس
المانيا خطوة غير متوقعة نحو
بكين متجاهلة اعلان امريكا ان
تعمه الفوضى وتعبث به الدول
الخارجية. ما عاد يطيق الانتظار
منذ عام الف وتسعمائة واربعة
وثمانين اي اكثر من ثمانية
التعاون مع دول العالم على مبدأ
المصالح المشتركة والاحترام
المفضلة. القوي لا يتم اجباره
بالقوة بل بالتفاوض. مبدأ بسيط
مساعدات عسكرية لاوكرانيا جدا.
فلما كل هذا الكرم الحاتمي
سنغتال بايدن. صحيفة نيويورك
بوست تصرح انه تمت قرصنتها من
الاسرائيليين قد سابقها مصرحين
انهم لن يدخلوا الحرب ولن يدعموا
لكن الصين لديها مبدأها الخاص.
فعن اي مبدأ نتحدث المبدأ الصيني
خلالها لتصبح الصين الشريك
التجاري الاول للمملكة. لتتخذ
وذلك بعدما صرح الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان قرارا كهذا
سيدمر علاقاتهما الثنائية.
وبينما تتجنب كثير من الدول دعم
ان شوتس يعارض فك الارتباط عن
الصين مشيرا الى ان زيارته الى
وعشرين عاما من الخبرة لبلادكم
في اطلاق الصواريخ. لعبة الصين
يجب على الولايات المتحدة ازالة
السلبية التي تؤثر على العلاقات
يتجه نحو السعودية حيث كشف وزير
الخارجية السعودي بن فرحان عن
ها هو ترامب يفعلها في زوجها
هجوم على منزل رئيسة مجلس النواب
دفاع حديثة للتصدي للغارات
الروسية على اراضيها لكن رد
بين جيشي البلدين اذا كانت تعتزم
امريكا حقا تعزيز الاتصال
وبعد يوم واحد من تهديدات امريكا
ان تنفيذ كوريا الشمالية اي ضربة
حدة التوترات. كوريا الجنوبية
تجري تدريبات عسكرية ضد الهجمات
الكيماوية مستعينة بروبوتات
وطائرات بدون طيار. بل تكفي هذه
في المائة من اختبارات كوريا
الشمالية لصواريخها ناجحة وذلك
اغتيال شخصيات سياسية من بينها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن. كيم
اوكرانيا عسكري. لن نبتعد كثيرا
فحال تل ابيب هو ذاته في كوريا
يعيش عليه اصحاب العيون الضيقة
ليخرج متحدث الدفاع الصيني قائلا
اوكرانيا ليمسك العصا من المنتصف
اعلنت واشنطن انها ستقدم حزمة
قد الاقوى منذ بداية الحرب
الاوكرانية فلمن ستكون الغلبة؟
قبل احد موظفيها وذلك بعد نشر
نصوص وتغريدات تدعو خصيصا الى
وخمسين عسكريا اوكرانيا واسقاط
ثلاث طائرات. فيما اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الاوكرانية ان موسكو عززت
قواتها في خرسون بنحو الف جندي
وبعد التحالف الروسي الايراني
خرجت كييف لتطالب تل ابيب بانظمة
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة. نعم. في
هذه اللحظات يا سادة هناك معركة
واجلاء المدنيين لتعلن وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تصفية مائة
ولم هذا الطلب يا بوتين? هنا
يجيب الرئيس الروسي بانه يعرف
نووية او اي تجارب اخرى سيعني
نهاية نظام كيم. وقبل ان يجف ريق
اطلقت صاروخين باليستيين قصيري
المدى قبالة سواحلها ومع تصاعد
المتحدث الامريكي الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي يعلن ان كوريا الشمالية
سفن اوكرانيا عندما ترى نتائجها
بخصوص شحن الحبوب والاسمدة
لقواعد الملاحة البحرية بحسب
الوزارة الروسية روسيا ستفرج عن
تأجيج واشنطن الى تصعيد موسكو
الخارجية الروسية تعلن انه تم
تتجه روسيا الى سياسة الارض
المحروقة بعد انسحابها من خرسون
الروسية وهذه بتلك يقولها الروس
للغربيين. ومن حروب التصريحات
لدينا القدرة على نشر قوات
عسكرية في اوروبا بشكل سريع. ومن
سترد بطريقة مناسبة على اي هجوم
روسي ضد اي اقمار صناعية امريكية
تصبح اهدافا مشروعة وهنا وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن.
لماذا يواصل بوتين الحديث عن
السلاح النووي اذا لم تكن له نية
نووية لاوكرانيا ولن نستخدم
النووية هناك. فانا فقط كنت ارد
في استخدامه. بينما تعهد البيت
الابيض بان الولايات المتحدة
ايقاف سبعين سفينة اوكرانية في
البحر الاسود لانها لم تمتثل
الى حروب اصوات وضجيج المدافع
السلطات الاوكرانية تتوقع ان
العربية السعودية. بوتين ايضا
وصل ارسال رسائله ولكن هذه المرة
توجه نحو الوكالة الدولية للطاقة
الذرية ليحث على زيارة اوكرانيا.
السعودية الى البريكس مؤكدا على
تطوير علاقتهم مع المملكة
عسكرية كانت او تجارية بعد ان
قال مسؤول روسي انها يمكن ان
عن الربيع المقبل. ليتأجج الوضع
النووي اكثر ويظهر بيض مصرحا
وهناك مسؤولون امريكيون قد
استبقوا الحدث ليعلنوا عن سرعة
تقديم موعد وصول قنبلة الجاذبية
الناتو الى ديسمبر المقبل بدلا
لعبت اعصابنا ليعود بوتين ويضيف
قائلا ما دامت الاسلحة النووية
موجودة فان خطر استخدامها يظل
قائما. اذا لنعد الى دواء الضغط
مجددا. ولكن هنا واشنطن قد اخذت
تهديدات بوتين على محمل الجد.
للتستر على اثار تحضيرها. ويضيف
بوتين لسنا بحاجة لتوجيه ضربة
على خصومي. فلماذا كل ذاك
التهديد والوعيد يا بوتين? لقد
هنا رائحة الاستخبارات الروسية.
مؤكدا ان كييف تبذل قصارى جهدها
بشكل تقريبي المكان الذي يعد فيه
الاوكرانيون القذرة وكأني اشتم
ان ابن سلمان يعمل لصالح بلاده.
واوضح بوتين ان تدعم انضمام
تحدث بوتين عن ولي العهد السعودي
بن سلمان وقال انه شاب ويجب
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يعيد للقارة العجوز بعضا من
عقدا هو الاكثر خطورة منذ الحرب
العالمية الثانية. من جانب اخر
احترامه والا تكون فظا معه حتى
لا يرد عليك بنفس الطريقة. مضيفا
سيئة تجاه الغرب فلا تعتقد ان
روسيا عدو لكم. فهل تدرك اوروبا
رسالة بوتين وشدد بوتين على ان
الغرب يلعب لعبة خطيرة ودموية
وقذرة بشأن اوكرانيا وذلك حسب
وصفه. لافتا الى ان العالم يدخل
الطمأنينة بقوله ان روسيا ليست
عدوا لاوروبا وليس لديها نوايا
هو ترامب ينتقم من الباسوس نانسي
بيلوسي. بوتين يقولها للعالم.
الشروط بينما المجنون يرد على
تهديدات امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية
تستعد. والمانيا تتخذ خطوة غير
متوقعة نحو الصين. والسعودية
اغتيال بايدن. بهذا العنوان
صحيفة عالمية تتورط مع
تقترب من بكين اكثر وواشنطن تعلق
والعراق بين الفوضى والنظام فهل
حان وقت بناء الدولة ومجلس الامن
الدولي يقول كلمته بشأن الصحراء
الامريكية واشنطن ترد وسبعون
سفينة اوكرانية تقع في قبضة
الغربية بان ترضى بها الجزائر
والمغرب وبعد ان وعدت بضربه ها
الروس بالبحر الاسود وروسيا تضع
شروطا لاعتاقها. فما هي هذه
الحرب تتأجج والاطراف تتحجج وكل
بدلوه في البئر الاوكراني. هنا
الاستخبارات الامريكية وبعد ان
هددت روس باسقاط الاقمار
تنشر سلاحا نووي جديدا بالقرب من
روسيا فكيف سترد موسكو? سيتم
احترامه. هكذا قالها بوتين. فما
الذي يخطط له يا ترى? وواشنطن
لسنا بحاجة لتوجيه ضربة نووية
لاوكرانيا. وبن سلمان شاب ويجب
ربع نسوان.
ثلاثة رصيد واحد.
دعمها لاوكرانيا. فهل اقتربت
المعركة